YUFENG GUO: Data is messy.
It's often unbalanced,
mislabeled,
and sprinkled with wacky values
that throw off your analysis
and machine learning training.
The first step to getting
your dataset cleaned up
is understanding where
it needs cleaning.
Today, I've got just
the tool for the job.
Understanding your
data is the first step
to getting your dataset cleaned
up for machine learning.
But this can be tricky
to do, especially
in any sort of
generalizable manner.
An open source project
from Google Research
called Facets can help
us visualize our data
and slice it in all
sorts of manners
which can help us begin to see
how our dataset is laid out.
By allowing us to find
where our data doesn't quite
look the way we're expecting,
Facets helps reduce mishaps
down the road.
Let's see what
Facets looks like.
The team has a demo
page on the web
so you can try out
Facets from Chrome
without installing anything.
Moreover, Facets visualizations
use Polymer Web Components
backed by a TypeScript
code so you can easily
embed this in web pages
and into Jupyter notebooks.
There are two parts to Facets--
Facets Overview and
Facets Deep Dive.
Let's take a look at each
one now in more detail.
Facets Overview gives-- well,
an overview of your dataset.
In previous videos, we
saw how tools like pandas
can help us get a sense of how
our dataset is distributed.
We can get a slightly
upgraded view
of this type of information
using the Facets Overview tool.
Facets Overview splits
the columns of our data
into rows of
salient information,
showing stuff such as percentage
missing, min and max values,
as well as stats like mean,
median, and standard deviation.
It also has a column that shows
the percentage of values that
are zeros, which totally helps
with catching cases where
most of your values are zeros.
You can also see these
distributions on your test
dataset as well as your
training set for each feature.
This way, you can
double-check that the test
set has a similar distribution
to the training dataset.
Yes, indeed,
technically this is best
practice to do at least this
level of analysis on your own
anyway, but I have
definitely forgotten
to check all of these aspects
of every column of my data.
This tool will help
ensure that you
don't miss this
crucial step, and it
highlights some abnormalities.
Now let's take a look
at Facets Deep Dive.
This is where things
get really interesting.
It allows you to have even
more clarity into your dataset
and zoom all the way in to see
an individual piece of data.
You can "facet" the
data by row and column
across any of the
features of your dataset.
This will look
familiar to views when
you're shopping online
for, say, shoes, and filter
by different categories, such
as size, brand, and color.
Let's take a look at a concrete
example of Deep Dive in action.
The interface is divided
up into four main sections.
The main area in the center is
a zoomable display of your data.
On the left-hand
panel is where you
can change the
arrangement of your data
with various
dropdowns to control
things like faceting,
positioning, and color.
Directly below that is a
legend for the center display,
and on the far right
is a detailed view
of a specific row of data.
You can click on any dot of
data in the center visualization
to see a detailed readout of
that particular data point.
Now let's see how this
all comes together.
To do this, we'll use
the "Census Dataset,"
a classic dataset extracted
from the 1994 US census
by Barry Becker.
Its target is to predict
whether a household's annual is
above or below $50,000, based
on various census statistics.
We'll first split the data
by age range and color
the data points based
on the target value.
Here, blue means less than 50K,
and red means greater than 50K.
Now we can look at
the breakdown, by age,
of another feature of the data--
say, do different
number of hours per week
yield different results
across age ranges?
Let's find out by faceting
columns by hours per week.
We can see that there is a
larger chunk of the age 17-26
population working 15 to 29
hours per week, which may just
be the result of kids doing
summer jobs, let's say.
And we can also see the trend of
fewer and fewer people working
29 to 43 hours per week as they
get older, while the 43 to 57
hour segment stays relatively
constant in the middle years
of the chart.
But this still
doesn't quite show us
what we are looking for.
So let's try changing the
positioning of the plot
and getting a more
detailed look.
We'll switch the
positioning to "Scatter"
and only facet by age.
I'm also going to
select "Hours per Week"
as our vertical
sort order to make
it easy to see the working hours
across different age groups.
Now we can see that indeed,
the hours per week rise
in the middle of the chart
and lower on either side.
You should continue
exploring this data
and see what trends and
relationships you can find.
For instance, you
might facet by country
of origin, which would show
that the data is heavily skewed,
and this might tell
you that you need
to collect more data points to
have a more balanced dataset.
If this was interesting,
you're probably
wondering how to get your
dataset loaded into Facets.
Well, here you have two options.
You can either use the web
interface and just upload
the data directly and play
with it in the browser,
or you can install the library
as a Jupyter notebook extension
using the instructions on the
project's GitHub page, which
I'll link below.
Facets is a useful tool
for peering into your data
and seeing the relationships
between different features,
as well as ensuring that
there aren't missing
or unexpected values
in your dataset.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
right when they come out.
Now go out there
and facet your data,
and see how you can improve
your machine learning.